all right the holiday season is here we
have ourselves a family movie a Santa
Claus movie bring the kids but before we
talk about it I want to take the sponsor
of this video this video is brought to
you by nordvpn the VPN service that
looks to make your navigating the
digital Minefield of the internet a
little say for a little more secure not
only can you change your digital
location with one click allowing you to
watch movies or shows that might not be
available in your region also my fellow
Gamers allows you to play video games
that might not be available in your
region but nordvpn also has threat
protection that sword and shield between
you and the internet blocks malware
written websites helps protect you and
your information from trackers and spies
you got to protect yourself and your
information maybe your computer getting
a virus will make you feel nostalgic
about the days of LimeWire but it's not
worth it so click the link below go to
nordvpn.com Johns and users can get a
huge discount with purchase of a
two-year plan plus four additional
months for free it's risk-free with
nord's 30-day money-back guarantee and I
love that and now sing it with me
violent night
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
so Violet Knight's new Christmas film
new Christmas classic well that's up to
you but it's pretty much the chatter
that you've heard unless you've never
heard of it in which case glad to
introduce you but the chatter online
that I've heard is this is Die Hard
meets home alone with Santa Claus die
hard yes home alone so sprinkled in
there and there's a scene but it's not
like the brick and mortar of the film
Die Hard yes that's in line which means
it's a pretty easy description it's
Christmas Eve John Leguizamo and his
crew of Bandits they infiltrate this
Mansion because they want all the money
that's in the vault and that is right
when Santa who's making his rounds that
night because his Christmas Eve ends up
at that house and so he's pretty much
the John McLean just funny because the
movie makes references to die hard and
home alone it's very it's very
self-aware and it being called violent
night and the poster being that well you
know Santa's about to beat some ass now
David Harbor as Santa Claus is
incredible in this film I first saw the
trailer at cinemacon and I was like
I need to watch that movie right now but
he's a vulnerable sanity he's been doing
this a while he's starting to question
what's it all for I mean people are
getting shittier I don't think the movie
actually expressly says that
specifically but
we're just being real here right so this
movie amazingly uses this Santa in a rut
premise
as Santa finding Redemption finding a
renewed sense of purpose of Christmas
like David Harbor as action movie Santa
Claus is exactly how it is in this movie
is exactly how he is you think of David
Harbor Santa in a rut Action Hero Santa
Claus time for some Seasons beatings
Santa Claus is coming to town
I gotta watch
yep but it's more than that it's more
than just guy in a Santa suit because
that's what it would have felt like it
would have felt like oh a guy in a Santa
suit if it was just David Harbor in a
Santa suit kicking ass the movie takes
strides to illustrate that this is Santa
Claus you know what feels like a
Christmas movie I'm not talking about
the goons in this movie having Christmas
code names I mean that's fun and all I'm
talking about Christmas themes and
Christmas music being woven into the
musical score the connection between
Santa Claus and this little girl is one
of the hostages in this house I thought
that was that was a huge amount of heart
in this film I didn't expect to be there
we didn't give me those heartfelt arcs
in a film that I didn't think were going
to be there I mean that's always a plus
also it being in a Christmas movie to
make it feel like a Christmas movie
that's even better also they do some
really cool things with Santa lore and
here you get a bit of backstory so you
can buy the fact that this Santa Claus
is actually able to kick ass and it
makes sense and little details the
devil's in the details when it comes to
lore like Santa Claus having to go to
the chimney and touch his nose to go up
the chimney I was like well that's how
it is in the story yeah I didn't have to
do that but I just appreciate these
little details where you can tell
someone's like no it's important that he
touches his nose there were some
characters in this movie that felt
cartoony it's almost a growing epidemic
I almost understand why because really
in terms of the hostages in terms of the
people who are in this Mansion it's the
little girl
and a crew of who gives a [ __ ] little
girl stole the show when it comes to the
hostages I think it's because she's the
reason Santa actually stuck around to
help she builds a bond with Santa Claus
but no one else did so it's like if it
was just a little girl this one hostage
and there was nobody else Santa would
have still stuck around on the other
hand if the little girl wasn't there and
it was just a crew of adults these
bickering family members um I don't know
that Santa would have stuck around so
there's that either case she's clearly
the valuable one for the heart and soul
of the film and everyone else is just
kind of there also yeah I feel like the
movie goes on for 10 minutes or so too
long I'm ballparker but I feel like this
whole new crew gets brought into this
movie just so Santa had more people to
bludgeon and kill on one hand fun when
it's happening pacing wise movie could
have been shorter but in the end I
absurdly enjoyed myself with this movie
I actually feel to its core it does
maintain the spirit of a Christmas
themed movie it has the Christmas spirit
alive live here also a lot of bloody
death
too I had a great time no alcohol
required I'll be honest with you I
enjoyed this movie I'm totally down for
a prequel and or a sequel I want to see
more from this world I want to see more
of the David Harbor Santa Claus all
right so violent night have you seen it
what did you think about it what's your
favorite Christmas movie of all time
sure I ask you that every December
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]